that to me is the scariest scary movie
ever what's this movie was terrifying is
it Close Encounters of the Fourth Kind
that takes her place in Alaska where
they they combine the actual footage of
the Woman's real
um therapy sessions and stuff I don't
know
Close Encounters of the Fourth Kind it's
it's third or fourth kind which one's
the original movie Third Kind so this
one's Fourth Kind I'm I'm almost
probably wrong I've never heard of it
it's a really good move there's a woman
up in um I want to say I want to say
Juno or no no no what's the uh gnome
gnome Alaska and back in the day she was
um she became famous because she claimed
uh aliens were basically like showing up
and abducting her and stuff right that
eventually her kid got abducted by
aliens
or so that's the case and they accused
her of like
killing the kid or whatever maybe
obviously nobody believes that this
woman's son was abductor daughter was
abducted by aliens so it's not currently
available in our country it's like in
Canada I think it's it's showing up
weird you can only get it in Canada I
don't know
what that's strange
interesting but they they have it's it's
a movie about this case but they splice
in real footage of her therapy sessions
she had to go to that she was going to
while she was being abducted each night
and they like they do this um I don't
really know how to describe it this deep
meditative state that makes you recall
your dreams and she's like describing
all the things that were happening to
her these aliens and she started
screaming she starts like levitating up
from the couch a little bit like it's
like it's creepy as [__] it's a really
good movie it's my favorite Abduction
movie I've ever seen and obviously
nobody believes her she runs into the
one person
oh yeah like the that old footage is
like the real footage wow
so
here's my issue with the alien abduction
thing
other than there's not like any real
solid evidence you could point to that's
very convincing
it always happens at night and it always
happens during the periods where people
sleep and when you're sleeping I'm not
saying always okay I'm sure there's some
stories out there I'm sorry but most of
the stories I've ever heard are people
in there bad they can't move aliens
abduct them or they're in a car the car
stops they wake up
aliens adopted them
when you go to sleep and you dream there
are psychedelic chemicals that your
brain makes and we don't know how much
they're making we don't know what effect
that's having on your dreams we don't
know what is going on what is going on
with dreams what is going on with vivid
dreams what is going on with dreams that
are
they're indiscernible from real life and
sometimes in a strange way like what is
that is that a psychedelic State your
brain goes into every night yeah and if
chemicals vary in human beings serotonin
varies dopamine varies everything varies
testosterone various estrogen varies it
varies
wouldn't you just assume those
psychedelic chemicals would vary and
when you wouldn't you just assume that
sometimes maybe even people are in uh
very agitated anxiety-ridden States High
cortisol levels perhaps maybe those
chemicals are coming out in an abundance
too now if you're a lying in bed and
you're having an insanely Vivid and
terrifying interaction with aliens every
night because your brain is just dumping
psychedelics into you and this is your
big fear so you're going to get abducted
by aliens again and then there they are
again leaning over your bed and they're
itching for your constant paranoia
and then here's the the mind [__] of all
mind [__] Maybe
psychedelics are a gateway to some other
reality some other dimension that's
accessible by these creatures I like
this and that when you are getting
abducted you really are getting abducted
like whatever your being is or your
spirit or whatever is you is getting
you're interacting with these things
and it feels real because it is real and
because we're thinking about the ability
to come in contact with other life forms
as being a physical thing it might be
that there's a chemical Gateway in your
mind that when breached you enter into a
dimension where physical bodies don't
exist anymore and everything moves in
this constant soup of geometric patterns
and that
whatever your Consciousness is whatever
your soul is is decoupled from the body
and thrown into this realm I imagine
that's probably what happens at death it
probably is what happens with death it's
probably what what it's all I mean
that's probably why people think about
it that way that you're going to
transcend into heaven you're going to go
into this new place it might be true it
might be like a lot of the old
depictions of like what happens when you
uh enter into a psychedelic State I've
heard this multiple times that it's like
a Well of Souls that you're interacting
with Souls that are like completely
unattached to a physical presence yeah
and maybe that is maybe you're getting
layers and layers of that depending upon
how [__] up you are where you're
sleeping and maybe some of those layers
are boom aliens are in the room with
healed back just aliens in the room with
you and maybe they can do that maybe
they can visit you while you're in those
States maybe that's what's happening too